hello everyone and welcome to a really
spectacular game that happened yesterday
in the video world cup it's adiban
versus uh grand master uh notice delgado
ramirez of paraguay
and it's uh quite a game it features two
really uh
well just exquisite positive video
moments so i'm sure you guys are going
to enjoy those
uh let's get straight to it so adiban
with the white pieces
opens with d4 we have knight to f6
c for e6 knight to c3 and now bishop to
b4 going for the nimzo indian defense
and now we often say here that queen the
c2 and e3 are the absolute most uh
popular replies here knight to f3 being
let's say the third one and there's of
course f3 the como
variation which was well very popular
for example in in the bobby fischer era
but it is also uh well somewhat popular
today
but just not as much as those other
continuations so here we have
f3 uh we have d5 black will pretty much
always play this move in the
uh when going for the name so indian and
now as f3 was played usually
when playing the names of indian you
want to play some like b6 c5 uh get the
knight into the game
you know play bishop to b7 maybe get the
rook 28 maybe somehow
get the queen into the game but here as
f3 has been played
black will not really play b6 and try
and get his bishop on this diagonal
because white already made sure
that he will be controlling the center
and especially these light squares here
so the bishop will not be all that
useful here
so here we have a3 challenging the
bishop bishop captures b
captures and now c6 black just
strengthens the
strengthens the center and now you can
see that uh black
has all of these pawns on light square
so it'd be great if you had a dark
square bishop so you could you know
cruise around those light square pawns
you have a light square bishop so it's
not
as great as if it was a dark square
bishop uh so black will have to
figure out how to deal with this we have
e4 now grabbing full control of the
center we have d
captures on e for f captures on e4 and
now
we have e5 and e5 is a move that's
almost exclusively played here i say
almost
because there is one game from 2004
between volkov and moisenko
where knight captures on e4 was played
this
this gambit was accepted but this is
basically a pre-engine era
and it's very very uh
hard to imagine that someone would play
this with black today for example queen
g4 goes after the pawn and the knight
knight goes back we have queen captures
here rook has to go here and now bishop
to g5 and it's already
i mean yeah it's it's looking really
nice for white knight d7 you have to
defend the knight rook d1 and white will
have a very very interesting game
so it's very interesting how how
moisence was able to employ this and
still win
uh against the grand master so after f
captures on e4 we have e5
like i said this is the most played move
here knight to f3 and now
queen to a5 developing with tempo as the
c3 pawn is under attack so bishop to d2
by adiban
and only now knight captures on e4 we
have bishop to d3
knight captures on b2 queen captures and
here e captures on d4
and there are a couple of games that
reach to this exact same position and in
all of them
c captures on d4 was played and but the
problem is
uh white never won a single game from
this position some were drawn some were
won by black but
it's not very very ambitious black will
trade queens and black has a
very nice game he pretty much solved all
of his problems the development of the
light square bishop is no longer an
issue
so instead after e capture sunday for
adiban who is now down upon
he just castles and he says let's let's
do this
so can black uh try and grab yet another
pawn if you play something like capture
so you could attack the queen here you
have a very nice
obviously not that you have a very nice
pass pawn here uh but uh you know just
queen e3 check and you're gonna be in a
lot of trouble for example bishop p6
knight g5 and it's already
looking very very ugly for uh for black
this is uh going to get
captured you can't really castle because
the bishop and knight already attacked
the h7 pawn
so it's uh it will be completely lost
for black so black of course not
interested in
going in that direction he simply
castles as well
and now his king is safe and now he will
continue the game
uh if you don't castle uh castling is
very dangerous here as you'll see but if
you try something like bishop to e6
you know try and uh defend a bit more
squares it's still
still very ugly for example knight g5
we're going to play knight to d7 now
and now black is trying to get white to
play knight captures here but this would
actually be fine for black the problem
is
white has rook captures on f7 and as
you'll see this
this game features so many of these
hidden gems that
it's uh simply amazing for example
bishop captures
rook to e1 with czech king f8 now queen
to f4 threatening checkmate
so you have to block it knight f6 but
now queen to d6 with
check king g8 and now knight captures on
f7
and here you're going to lose a lot of
material uh or if you don't want to lose
a lot of material you're going to lose
the game for example king captures an f7
you're going to play rookie 7 check
and now it doesn't matter if you go here
just queen e6 if you go here then well
that's a problem just rook captures
anything here with a discovery king g8
26 check here
and we can deliver a nice checkmate here
so just to give you an idea of how
dangerous this position is
uh regardless of whether black castles
or tries to develop with bishop to e6 or
plays anything really
so black did castle but as i've said
knight to g5 going after the h7 pawn
and now if you defend with h6 it again
loses
it just loses the game for black knight
captures on f7 and that's it rook
captures queen e2 now
and there's not much uh you can do you
can't allow really queen to e8 to check
because that would be
a a double attack here and if you go
queen to d8 that
will help out with the defense uh then
just rook captures on f7 king captures
rook to f1 check the bishop covers the
h7 square so that's going to be an issue
and after the king moves just queen e4
you're going to get checkmated the real
covers df file there is no defending
this
so uh very nice so after knight g5 we
have f5 instead of the h6 now preventing
this bishop
from being of any use but not really
adiban finds another great idea and that
is
c5 c5 is the only good move for white
here and that makes it all the
uh all the better for for white to find
this it it kind of
blocks the queen from entering the game
right away but also
has the immediate thread of queen to a
to check and then you're just getting
crushed with knight to f7 check and so
on
so here king the h8 preventing this and
now
queen to e2 so again what do you play
here
uh well uh you could play queen captures
on c5 this is uh
black's most resilient reply uh but
still queen h5 goes after the h7 pawn h6
and again knight
to f7 check king g8 knight captures on
h6g captures and now that we have this
very standard checkmating pattern king
h8 queen captures king goes back queen
g6 check king h8
and now of course a very nice rook lift
and that's it black is now getting
checkmated
and of course you can play this to guard
the h3 square with your bishop because
then
well you're getting checkmated again so
instead after queen to a2 we have knight
to d7 but now
we've actually reached our first pause
the video moment so feel free to pause
the video here
and try to find the only one move that
wins the game for adiban while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
not stopping for anything uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
knight captures on h7 as i'm sure many
of you guys
found this but this is only our first
pause the video moment so here uh
you could uh capture this but you know
if you go for this captures then queen
to h5 check
and it's a very quick checkmate king
goes here now bishop to c for check one
of the reasons why
uh queen really needed to capture this
to kind of block the c4 square but there
was never
an opportunity to do this now you have
to give up the rook captures and after
the king moves just queen h5 check made
the bishop covers g8 it's a game over
so instead after knight captures an h7
we have d captures on c3
uh and now queen to h5 and only now
uh queen captures on c5 this comes with
check so of course it makes sense to do
this instead of something like king to
g8 but i'm just going to show you
that it's the same because bishop c4
check and you run into the exact same
checkmate
so queen captures and c5 is a must king
the h1 and now
king the g8 unpinning while also keeping
an eye on the c4 square so you don't
have this
check but now comes bishop captures an
f5 and
black's position is completely busted
here of course bishop to e6 is coming so
we have queen to d5 guarding the square
but now knight to g5 the knight now
covers d squares queen to h7 is the
threat of checkmate
so knight to f6 guarding the h7 square
but now feel free to pause the video and
try to find
the second incredible idea while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on always
boldly going where no man has gone
before and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's queen to h7
and no this time i'm not tricking you it
actually is queen to h7 check so the
move
that was played on the previous move
knight to f6 to prevent queen to h7
didn't really prevent anything because
now uh it was in this position animal 22
yes we are still only at move 22 even
though we've checked out a lot of lines
uh was uh that and nurez delgado ramirez
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so you don't have
any squares you have to capture the
queen
but once the queen is captured then
again a very very standard checkmating
pattern bishop captures an h7 check
king to h8 only move now comes rook
captures nf8 and again only move queen
to g8
followed by rook captures on g8 and
we've
reached the position from the thumbnail
and there you have it that's how this
and this happened
uh even though you know it's it's very
hard to imagine something like this
happening with
white being up material white completely
stifling black like this and you know
how does it happen this is how it
happens uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
i enjoyed it incredible performance by
adiban who always
brings out uh you know the the best in
chess however he plays whether he wins
or loses his games are always you know
just uh
a joy to watch you know uh some would
even charge
you know to show his games uh if this
was let's say the 18th century
uh but yeah once again i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
you kaminsky my friends air tom
daralao73753022052 and
david kimura for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
world cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day